what am i absolute favorite people it's
Matt Braunger that's you Matthew it's me
[Music]
Matthew brunker yep did your father yell
Matthew and who's Maddie you know my
mother did my mom found out I think when
I was Joyce I was named after the saint
but she found when I was like three my
dad was like I was like two marshal Matt
Dillon on Gunsmoke so you were named
after Gunsmoke named after TV cowboy
Matthew I know you from Chicago town yes
ye olde Chicago town and but you're not
from there you're from the Portland
State yes I am of Oregon yep
Portland City that's right where they
have doughnuts with bacon in them is
that true yeah there's bacon doughnuts
so yeah it's a bacon maple and get it
voodoo doughnuts where they used to have
the nyquil doughnut but then the I think
the the Food and Drug Administration was
like uh-uh no you don't get to sell that
clown story yes or false this is what I
like to do sometimes I take a comedian
and it's funny how how premises and then
we put him under the blinding light of
truth and say is it real absolutely real
one thing I left out for time was my
friend Dan who's my height about 64 was
dancing the bar with a girl and the girl
fell behind the bar and she as she fell
she grabbed his clown suit and took him
with her and he went sideways into a
sliding beer cooler and shattered the
whole glass shut all of it and the whole
bar did a collective like Oh like he's
dead you know we all were in our heads
were like this evening has gone has gone
the horrible way the wrong way we'll
always remember the time we watched our
friend die and as a clown while we were
wearing clown suits right we are to
blame and he he did the classic just
popped up was like uh okay it was like
Mardi Gras in the streets
there's no no bigger happiness bursts of
relief then oh my god he's dead
no he's alive he's fine oh my gosh that
would be a pretty great way to go if you
were in Chicago at a pretty exciting
time together we started similar to
stand-up and we had mustaches when
you're in Chicago if you don't have a
mustache get out you're out if you're
able to grow a mustache that in Dubai I
had I had a beard but I had like a
family ties dad beard if you had a beard
I would expect you to teach me life
lessons I hat well no but it was it was
one of those weird things that made me
look way older than I was and but I was
still wearing like t-shirts and shorts
yeah Christian youth leader kind of like
why why did you a great buzz strap let's
play some shine Jesus shot here's a
guitar did you go to youth group no well
I was tricked into going for a weekend
once I went to to get a girl to notice
me no no the church group yeah you went
because you had a crush on one of the
Christian girls and they showed a video
of a guy lying to be in a church because
he wanted to sleep with the girls I'm
not sure do you want to have sex with a
girl oh yeah I believe in your Lord no
one will know later Matt was dead
everybody calls me the corruptor I don't
know this looks like the corruptor that
one yeah this isn't that you know what
the idea of that came from 70's albums
where a guy is just in the middle of the
woods wearing a pristine suit and you're
like how the hell did you get there it's
called shovel fighter yes it's based on
a bit I do where I basically say the
worst job I ever had which is true was
when I worked in a greeting-card store
because they're so boring you stare into
the abyss and the abyss stares back but
then I'd say I'd cut myself I'll be like
no no no wait no I lied the worst job
I've ever had was when I was a shovel
fighter in the Ukraine I go in a story
about how I had to fight people to death
with a shovel and I'm starving the
warlord makes me kill my best friend
that drew something in the sand to make
me happy and I cut his head off and I
start crying onstage as well as jokes
that either crushes or people are like
oh no welcome to Ukraine carpenter or
fight with shovel your choice your
choice is is either one we land of
opportunity to but there is no third job
no third job not want to meet guy asked
for third
both guys we hit with the shovel then go
home and sleep in health car from their
male ok poor Eastern European they just
go stereotyped and soak up the night
which I have several times
look how serious you are that we're so
mad
that's that's me making fun of the
Rockstar comedian idea because I think
we're all goofs and I think anyone who's
just like anyone who gets on stage and
does you know an hour of D jokes and
whatever and then gets off and is just
like yeah really the attitude has you're
a clown
you're a clown with a honking nose
Matthew Berger Matt Braunger everybody
check out his new album shovel fighter
get his old album soaked up tonight a
real pleasure you thanks Michigan I love
you very much I love you too man
[Music]